und irgendwo müsste dann hier re fabisch
genau das steht dann hierbei oder es
steht irgendwie in den titel
das ist wirklich verdammt verrückt finde
ich und hier ist es auch schon was mir
erst mal auffällt wir haben gar keine
originale ein verpacken etwas geht ab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem 9 mio
leute ich hoffe natürlich er ist gut wir
haben heute tatsächlich zum aller ersten
mal hier mal eine neue dreh location auf
dem hauptkanal also aus dieser
perspektive werdet ihr jetzt
wahrscheinlich öfter die videos sehen
natürlich im hintergrund wird noch ein
bisschen angepasst jetzt mit der zeit da
siehst ja noch bisschen kahl aus nur
deshalb noch sehr dass sich dann weißt
du nicht da fehlen noch vorhängen und
alles und ich brauche schon noch so ein
bisschen heil schutz
wie auch immer man das nennen dann wird
es auf jeden fall mit der zeit immer
besser und besser
wir machen heute auf jeden fall
folgendes ich hab mir ja man kann schon
sagen neue kleine kategorie überlegt und
zwar geht es dabei um sogenannte reverse
fordert für die leute die damit nichts
anfangen können das sind halt produkte
die wieder aufbereitet wurden deren
zustand quasi wie neu ist sie allerdings
schon mal in benutzung bahn und
irgendwie wieder zurückging weil
irgendwo eine kleine macke dran war
sonst vielleicht auch generalüberholt
bestimmte mahlgrad oder ich hab nämlich
letztens auch frisch zufälligerweise
also das gibt es wahrscheinlich schon
länger ich hab's noch nie gesehen hier
oben gibt es im reiter marken und dann
werden wir hier alle möglichen bekannten
marken die es so gibt vorgeschlagen
wenn man hier einfach mal auf apple
drückt kommen extrem viele produkte für
ja ich würde schon sagen relativ
preiswertes geld und ich dachte mir das
ist auf jeden fall anreiz genug mal
irgendwas davon zu bestellen um zu
schauen ob das denn wirklich toller
manier zum beispiel drauf drückt das ist
jetzt ein apple iphone 6 s und irgendwo
müsste dann hier in rif arabisch genau
das steht dann hierbei oder es steht
irgendwie in den titel hier zum beispiel
generalüberholt apple iphone 616 er bei
106 50 euro das ist schon gar nicht so
günstig wie haben für das heutige video
allerdings jetzt nicht so viele produkte
bestellt um genau zu sein ein gericht
nur eins alter ja ja wo ist es denn
jetzt manieren es handelt sich hierbei
um 100 prozent original apple iphone 4s
dinger was ist absolut von von sonst an
und das wurde halt auch sozusagen wieder
aufbereitet für 25 euro
das habe ich direkt bestellt und es ist
auch ziemlich schon angekommen darum
geht's halt heute ich wollte erst mal so
ein bisschen low anfang und wenn ihr das
feiert dann bestelle ich immer mehr
sachen es gibt auch playstation und so
was alles das könnte man auf jeden fall
aufmachen oder ihr schreibt mir eure
wünsche die kommentare ich meine ich
hätte das damals in weiß gestellt wir
schauen uns einfach mal rein und war im
moment ganz gut hier ist übrigens moment
so sieht das paket aus was mich jetzt
noch ganz kurz interessieren würde
wäre wie teuer ein iphone 4s denn
aktuell ist gibt es überhaupt noch wo
das sind jetzt zwar neue produkte denke
ich mal 70 euro 80 euro 60 euro aber
meint dass ich jetzt hier liegen hat ist
ja auch an sich wie 9
also ich glaube für 25 euro kann man
nicht meckern deswegen machen wir das
jetzt mal ob ich bin echt gespannt
ich kann mich noch super gut daran
erinnern wie damals so freunde von mir
dann vielleicht auch schon ein iphone 4s
hatten und du dachtest diese partie
haben iphone leiter ich will aus und
denken haben aber es war halt viel zu
teuer und jetzt habe ich hier einfach
eins liegen für 25 euro
das ist wirklich verdammt verrückt finde
ich und hier ist es auch schon was mir
erst mal auffällt wir haben gar keine
originale iphone verpackung also hier
steht auf denen ich weiß auch nicht wie
das damals war vielleicht ist die
original keine ahnung und eingepackt war
es jetzt gar nicht mehr zeit
okay okay wir haben jetzt hier ein
iphone 4s mit sage und schreibe 8 gb
alter vor allem meint ihr nicht so in
einigen jahren ist das viel mehr wert
als 25 euro also das gehalt obwohl ich
weiß nicht ob ich behalte oder ob ich
das verschenken oder was auch immer ich
damit mache ihr könnt ja meine
kommentare schreiben was ihr meint ob
das bald viel mehr wert ist sozusagen
ich würde schon einschätzen dass die
chancen gar nicht so schlecht sind
packen wir das jetzt mal weiter aus was
ist denn jetzt noch einen kopfhörer
was war das
wir haben ja noch gar nicht diesen
leipnik anschluss sondern sie es denn
nochmal designed by apple in california
okay das war also damals so wie es auch
heute immer noch ist sagt welcome to
reifen also ich glaube die originale
beschreibung gefehlt hier haben wir dann
den adapter und kassel hatte kann
wir haben heute gebt euch mal diesen
anschluss hier
er passt perfekt sagt hier unten rein
immer wir fett einfach an die kids ihr
wisst wahrscheinlich gar nicht dass das
damals mal so aussahen und hast ja mehr
haben wir gar nicht bei dass ist ein
bisschen schade also kopfhörer genau die
konzerne als auch hier oben rein stecken
da war das noch mal extra anschluss und
was ich aber wirklich sagen muss wir
haben absolut keinen kratzer oder sonst
was dann also das ringen ist wirklich
wie neu er war halt irgendwas dran an
der software oder wo auch immer und
hamburg zurückgeschickt überarbeitet und
jetzt ist es meins tut wir hoffen wir
dass es einfach angeschaut was man auch
sagen muss irgendwann konnte man diese
alten iphones ja gar nicht mehr updaten
also das neue ios update ist tatsächlich
drauf keine ahnung wann das ding
geblieben ist weswegen das weiß ich
jetzt langsam hochgefahren ist
wahrscheinlich total veraltet aussieht
ich bin mal gespannt wann das war auch
wirklich ewig immer noch nicht
hochgefahren jetzt kommt streng nicht an
jetzt steht hier einfach iphone konnte
nicht aktiviert werden da der
aktivierung server nicht erreichbar ist
versuchen sie das iphone über itunes zu
aktivieren oder probieren sie es in
einigen
okay jetzt kann ich hier in kot
installieren zeigt seit ich versuche das
mal eben so weit einzurichten aber das
hier ist mal kurz zum vergleich das
iphone 4s und das iphone 11 sonst
natürlich auch noch mal von nah ich
finde ja da hat sich schon einiges getan
okay leute ich bin jetzt drin also ich
muss sagen sieht eigentlich alles ganz
gut aus so wie man es erwartet hatte
also es sieht halt absolut nach einer 90
grad mal die kamera checken weil früher
ging das kann man das auch nicht mehr so
brier war das immer so dann ging dann
irgendwie sonne heißt für dich zu
beschreiben sondern nur eine spielhalle
gegen so aus man foto gemacht hat aber
das ist anscheinend auch nicht mehr so
leute wir sind immer sonntags dann
aufgefallen die ich euch gerne zeigen
würde und zwar also so hier kann man das
nachsehen
das gerät sieht wirklich top aus also da
sind überhaupt keine kratzer rich ich
frage mich wo die überhaupt so alte
iphone 4 die wären ja gar nicht
hergestellt wo neben die sowas her dass
es anscheinend noch nie benutzt wurde wo
oder wie auch immer früher war es auch
noch so man musste so nach rechts
wischen hier vielleicht haben wir also
so sieht das aus aber das unterscheidet
sich jetzt nicht so krass vom vom iphone
gut wobei wir schon natürlich einen
unterschied haben ich muss sagen ich bin
wirklich begeistert von den dingen und
was ich auch noch gemerkt habe was ich
glaube nicht dass das normal war
du kannst hier so man hört das glaube
ich auch hier finden wurde das glaub ich
auch gemacht also wenn ich jetzt mehr
ziehen würde wird das glaube ich auch
gehen deswegen lasse ich es mal besser
oder wird weil iphones waren ja an sich
aber so total verschlossen haben die
konzerne
ich überlege schon fast ob ich doch
nicht behalten soll ja ich weiß nicht
mal wie ich habe ein geschenk für dich
hab dir ein neues iphone besorgen möchte
es mal sehen recht freut sich schon ich
mein iphone
die qualität ist gut oder ist nix dran
außer hier das ist ein bisschen komisch
jungs haben einfach immer auch in
konstanz aufmachen aber ja aber das ist
ordentlich irgendwie noch nie
runtergefallen hoffe ich zumindest also
keine ahnung was da wird schon passiert
ist na klar ist das original das ist
sogar von der macht man bild vom wie
wird das wetter heute das muss man sich
mal vorstellen das gab es schon ich
glaube das ist dann ist das rauskommt
2011 2011 ging das schon leute das foto
bleibe ich euch mal hier ein
willst du einfach mal nur da kann ich
2000 leute ich hab gerade mal gecheckt
ob das ergab hat aber ist klar was gab
es da noch nicht aber was ich kann so
siri damals dass das schon funktioniert
hat das war seiner zeit voraus
mein fazit ist dass es auf jeden fall
sehr interessant sein könnte wenn man
noch mehr solche produkte bestellt ihr
könnt ja sofern an den kommentar
schreiben was ich bestellen sollen die
playstation das mache ich denke ich safe
also das geht halt auch und wenn jemand
von euch dieses schöne iphone 4s haben
möchte warum auch immer habe ich mir
gerade überlegt verlose ich das einfach
hier auf youtube unter euch hat waren
die kommentare was euer erstes handy war
handy smartphone was aber
so wie mir irgendwann raus und schreibt
dann am besten auf in seinem land zu
schreiben
genau lässt mir sogar gerne daumen nach
oben dafür weitere solcher videos ich
weiß dass heute weist ein bisschen
kürzer aber ich kann euch nur empfehlen
also wenn ich irgendwas braucht schaut
doch mal nach bei diesem service product
so wie ich das jetzt euch eben gezeigt
habe da gibt es glaube ich wirklich
alles und das hier bis absolut in
ordnung ein originales einfach von
wunsch dass ich das noch erleben dass
mir haut rein aber nicht den kanal
zschau